Deep learning has enabled us tobuild detailed specialized AI models,
and we can do that provided we gather enough data,
label it, and usethat to train and deploy those models.
Models like customer service chatbots or fraud detection inbanking.
Now, in the past if you wanted to build a new model for your specialization -
so, say a model forpredictive maintenance in manufacturing -
well, you’d need to start again with data selectionand curation,
labeling, model development,training, and validation.
But foundation modelsare changing that paradigm.
So what is a foundation model?
A foundation model is a more focused, centralized effort to createa base model.
And, through fine tuning, that base foundation model can be adapted to a specializedmodel.
Need an AI model for programming language translation?
Well, start with a foundational model
andthen fine tune it with programming language data.
Fine tuning and adapting base foundationmodels rapidly speeds up AI model development.
So, how do we do that?
Let’s look at the fivestages of the workflow to create an AI model.
Stage 1 is to prepare the data.
Now in this stage we need to trainour AI model with the data we're going to use,
and we're going to need a lot of data.
Potentially petabytes of data acrossdozens of domains.
The data can combine both available open source data and proprietarydata.
Now this stage performs a series of data processing tasks.
Those includecategorization which describes what the data is.
So which data is English, which is German?
Whichis Ansible which is Java? That sort of thing.
Then the data is also applied with a filtere.
So filtering allows us to, for example, apply filters for hate speech,
and profanity and abuse, and that sort of thing.
Stuff we want to filter out of the system that we don't train the model on it.
Other filters may flag copyrighted material, private or sensitive information.
Something else we're going to take out is  duplicate data as well.
So we're going to remove that from there.
And then that leaves us with something called a base data pile.
So that's really the output of stage one.
And this base data pile can be versioned and tagged.
Andthat allows us to say, "This is what I’m training the AI model on, and here are thefilters I used".
It's perfect for governance.
Now, Stage 2 is to train the model.
And we're going to train the model on those base data piles.
So we startthis stage by picking the foundational model we want to use.
So we will select our model.
Now, there are many types of foundation models.
There are generative foundationmodels, encoder-only models, lightweight models, high parameter models.
Are you looking to build anAI model to use as a chatbot, or as a classifier?
So pick the foundational model that matches your usecase,
then match the data pile with that model.
Next we take the data pile and we tokenize it.
Foundation models work with tokens rather than words, and a data pile could resultin potentially trillions of tokens.
And now we can engage the process of training using all of those tokens.
This process can take a long time, depending on the size of the model.
Large scale foundationmodels can take months with many thousands of GPUs.
But, once it’s done, the longest andhighest computational costs are behind us.
Stage 3 is "validate".
When training isfinished we benchmark the model.
And this involves running the model
and assessing itsperformance against a set of benchmarks
that help define the quality of the model.
And then from here we can create a model card
that says this is the model I’ve trained
andthese are the benchmark scores it has achieved.
Now up until this point the main persona thathas performed these tasks
is the data scientist.
Now Stage 4 is "tune",
and this is where we bring in thepersona of the application developer.
This persona does not need to be an AI expert.
They engage withthe model, generating - for example - prompts that elicit good performance from the model.
Theycan provide additional local data to fine tune the model
to improve its performance.
And this stage is something that you can do in hours or days -
much quickerthan building a model from scratch.
And now we’re ready for Stage 5, which is to deployment the model.
Now thismodel could run as as service offering deployed to a public cloud.
Or we could, alternatively, embed the model into anapplication that runs much closer to the edgeof the network.
Either way we can continueto iterate and improve the model over time.
Now here at IBM we’ve announced a platformthat enables all 5 of the stages of this workflow.
And It’s called watsonx and it’s composed ofthree elements.
So we have: watsonx.data, watsonx.governance, and watsonx.ai.,
and this all built on IBM’shybrid cloud platform which is Red Hat OpenShift.
Now Watsonx.data is a modern data lakehouse
and establishes connections with the datarepositories that make up the data inStage 1.
Watsonx.governance manages the data cards from Stage 1 and model cards fromStage 3
enabling a collection of fact sheets that ensure a well-governed AI process andlifecycle.
And watsonx.ai provides a means for the application developer personato engage with the model in Stage 4.
Overall foundation models are changingthe way we build specialized AI models
and this 5-stage workflow allows teams tocreate AI and AI-derived applications
with greater sophistication while rapidlyspeeding up AI model development.